it's not just the government talking
tough on the Asylum crisis the man in
the orange top from Sudan is the
self-styled leader of this group of
Asylum Seekers they're feeling angry
every day between them they've all moved
from two hotels in East London where
there were standoffs with the home
office refusing to leave before finally
agreeing to be transferred to new
accommodation an hour and a half away
they say they won't move to another
hotel let alone a barge if you get asked
to move again to another hotel no no no
no no no I I can't move
I can't move
I will make protest
all or all the people here I I invite
them to make protests in front of hotel
what do you say to people who say your
accommodation is being paid for by the
British taxpayer so the government can
send you to whichever Hotel they want to
I have been near to to be two years how
can I you're saying you're settled yeah
yeah the home office won't say exactly
who is destined for its three-story
floating barge the Bibby Stockholm
currently in Port in Genoa in Italy it
will be birthed in Portland Harbor much
to the opposition of Dorset Council and
house 500 Asylum seekers in what the
government describes as basic
accommodation we're bringing forward
alternative sites like indeed the barge
that we've announced today that will
save us money and indeed reduce pressure
on hotels all part of our plan to stop
the boat currently six million pounds a
day is being spent on housing 51 000
Asylum seekers in hundreds of hotels
this man from Sudan has been in six of
them in three years if the government
tries to send you to a barge what will
be your reaction
uh no I don't want to go
I don't want to go anymore you say you
don't want to go but what what will you
do I go homeless
by homeless he means he'll disappear
from the Asylum system living outside of
society something we're increasingly
hearing from people who also say they're
afraid of being sent to Rwanda
yet hours before the government's barge
announcement Sky News filmed three boats
packed with migrants leaving a beach in
Dunkirk in northern France
those who successfully make the journey
will arrive as the government continues
to unveil a strategy aimed at deterring
people from trying to cross the channel
Lisa Holland Sky News